these are the pictures you've seen of
January 6th
they're familiar because they've been
playing on a loop on every media Outlet
in America for the last two years
there's a reason for that
but it turns out there's quite a bit of
video you haven't seen and that video
tells a very different story about what
happened on January 6th more than 40
thousand hours or surveillance footage
from in and around the capitol have been
withheld from the public and once you
see the video you'll understand why
taken as a whole the video record does
not support the claim that January 6 was
an Insurrection in fact it demolishes
that claim
and that's exactly why the Democratic
party and its allies in the media
prevented you from seeing it by
controlling the images you were allowed
to view from January 6th they controlled
how the public understood that day they
could lie about what happened and you
would never know the difference
those lies had a purpose they created a
pretext for a federal Crackdown on
opponents of the uniparty in Washington
our office wanted to ensure that there
was shock and awe that we could charge
as many people as possible the first
thing you notice from viewing the full
video record of January 6th is just how
many people entered the Capitol building
that day hundreds and hundreds of people
possibly thousands over the course of
about two hours the crowd was enormous a
small percentage of them were Hooligans
they committed vandalism you've seen
their pictures again and again
but the overwhelming majority weren't
they were peaceful they were orderly and
meek these were not insurrectionists
they were sightseers footage from inside
the capitol overturns the story you've
heard about January 6th protesters queue
up in neat little lines they give each
other tours outside the speaker's office
they take cheerful selfies and they
smile they're not destroying the capital
they obviously Revere the capital
they're there because they believe the
election was stolen from them they
believe in the system
here's the man you've heard referred to
as the Q Anon Shaman outside the Senate
chamber these are not rioters these are
people who wandered over from a
political rally we will not let them
silence your voices after the rally they
walk down Pennsylvania Avenue where
organizers had secured a federal permit
to hold a legal rally on the grounds of
the Capitol I know that everyone here
will soon be marching over to the
Capitol Building
to peacefully and patriotically make
your voices heard once at the Capitol
Building Things began to get chaotic
Capitol police officers fired tear gas
into the crowd a few at the front of the
herd broke Windows someone opened the
doors and many hundreds of others just
walked in
of course they did make it the story and
at the center of it the single most
famous person arrested that day was a
Navy veteran from Arizona called Jacob
chansley often referred to as the Q Anon
Shaman the so-called Q Anon Shaman Q
Anon Shaman someone named Q Shaman Jacob
chansley became the face of January 6th
a dangerous conspiracy theorist dressed
in outlandish costume who led the
violent Insurrection to overthrow
American democracy for these crimes
chansley was sentenced to nearly four
years in prison far more time than many
violent criminals now receive what did
Jacob chansley do to receive this
punishment to this day there is dispute
over how chansley got into the Capitol
building but according to our review of
the internal surveillance video it is
very clear what happened once he got
inside virtually every moment of his
time inside the capital was caught on
tape the tape show that Capitol Police
never stopped Jacob chansley they helped
him they acted as his tour guides here's
video of chansley in the Senate chamber
Capitol police officers take him to
multiple entrances and even try to open
lock doors for him
we counted at least nine officers who
were within touching distance of unarmed
Jacob chansley not one of them even
tried to slow him down
chancelly understood that Capitol Police
were his allies video shows him giving
thanks for them in a prayer on the floor
of the Senate watch
contrast the reality of what Jacob
chansley did in the Capitol building on
January 6th the indisputable facts
recorded on video some of which has
never before been seen with the
depiction of Jacob chansley that you've
seen in the media for more than two
years he's a terrorist they said he
should be killed shoot him shoot him
like if it you burst into the United
States that if he was dressed like Bin
Laden would have shot him shoot him
shoot him
it makes you wonder who are the violent
extremists here not Jacob chansley and
the video proves that but she would
never have known from the media coverage
the people sitting in the chairs
need to be sitting in a jail cell
chansley is in a jail cell he's been
there for months
if he was in fact committing such a
grave crime why didn't the officers who
were standing right next to him Place
him under arrest
until now no one could even prove that
even happened
but it did
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight